OC is a national security threat
due to its parent companies ties to the Chinese Communist Party
and how user data is stored.
The house passed a bipartisan Bill
that would require the popular app to be
sold by its Chinese parent company
or be banned on American devices.
This is Alia James.
Spoke to local content creators
about what this band would mean to them.
Lawmakers on Capitol Hill are pushing for a Bill
that could be on the popular social media app TikTok.
And I spoke with many influencers,
and they told me that this could be a hard hit for the economy.
Content creators here in the Low Country
are pushing back against recent efforts by lawmakers
to be on TikTok,
a popular social media app where users can share videos.
I think it's silly, in my opinion.
I think TikTok is given something to people
in the way that social media maybe originally was supposed to be.
The concerns are centered around the app's parent company, ByteDance,
and it ties to the Chinese Communist Party.
Lawmakers say
the Chinese government could collect user data from American users,
making it a national security threat.
I can understand why.
I guess the powers that be in government don't like the
amount of person to person information sharing,
but that's also why the people love it.
You know, we've gotten to a point where we can't really, um,
trust all of the things that are being said to us.
But what I can trust is someone's POV.
What I can trust is someone's heartfelt, lived experience.
While creators on the app understand the security concerns,
they're urging lawmakers to consider the negative impact
that banning TikTok would have on small businesses and influencers,
many of whom consider it a main source of income.
A lot of us get our revenue,
you know, our money income from the platform.
Being able to have a platform on TikTok and itself is a blessing.
But when it comes to the whole actuality of it all,
we have to remember that content creators
make money through their content
because you have brands that are looking at them.
Most of South Carolina representatives voted to support the Bill.
The Bill now heads to the Senate,
where it faces an uncertain fate.
Reporting him out. Pleasant.
I'm Delilah James. Count on two.